and today when you decided to kind of
move away from pj & duncan and become
Ant & Dec rebrand yourself as active
dick
you went through a sort of makeover
didn't you a kind of extreme makeover
yes yeah we did but it wasn't our idea
but we yeah we wanted to ditch the
name's PG and I'm gonna be come on and
debt our real names yeah so I think was
Smash Hits magazine so you should do
like an image makeover why don't you do
that so it'll work really well yeah yeah
so Ann said I've shaved my head okay to
do that looks silly like that so I'll
dye me here so the idea was to dyeing my
hair blonde up but it just went ginger
wasn't quite the look we were going for
so this is the copper you've got there
yeah it's not it's vibrant yellow that
what I would say is though so that
happened and you obviously saw that in
vibrant color understand you then did a
shoot for a gay magazine attitude yeah
before we can tone this down and sex it
up what this it down the bottom there
there there oh yeah
added a [__] saloon or soil in your hair
in clay pretty much I did and then there
is a brilliant picture inside this is
Gillian no don't worry aunt you're safe
this is this is dick and they want to
know what the instruction was what the
photographer said today but he must said
oh you're in a gay magazine do something
that will really appeal to the game
you know they just makes in your home
boys up religiosity different times copy
by the way
McKenney were kind of looking for those
yeah and then we night as Justin Bieber
was sitting two rows behind us and we
thought you know what Valentine's Day my
boyfriend was a killer and he also slept
with my my half-sister slash cousin
because it was dark and he couldn't tell
his heart